of course there are lots of scenes in
the harry potter books that didn't make
it into the films
but did you know that there are also
plenty of moments in the movies that jk
rowling didn't actually write
discover which movie moments were
created by the filmmakers
from important interactions between
characters to funny lines that provide
some much needed light relief
there's a whole scene that inspired a
lego set and there's even an entire
character that didn't exist in the
novels
in the deathly hallows part one harry
and hermione take a moment to break the
tension during their long tense horcrux
hunt
while nick cave's oh children plays in
the background harry pulls hermione up
for a dance
she's reluctant at first but then starts
to smile along with harry as they twirl
each other around
it's an important scene as it explores
their platonic friendship
there's no hint of romance in it just
two close buddies supporting one another
if only ron could have seen them he'd
know there was no need to worry
something was going on between them
sorry harry and hermione shippers i saw
you two the other night
brothers that's nothing in the books
molly weasley made it clear that it
wasn't okay for sirius to treat harry as
if he was his best friend
james but the order of the phoenix movie
takes that even further
making it explicit that sirius mistook
harry for james in the department of
mysteries
the look on harry's face sums up the
devastation he feels
realizing that his godfather's
connection to him was mainly due to his
connection with harry's late father
it harks back to the flashback scene in
snape's worst memory too
when james uses expelliarmus and sirius
says the exact same phrase
there's another dancing scene that
wasn't in the books but this one is
lighthearted and funny
in the goblet of fire movie professor
mcgonagall teaches students how to dance
in preparation for the yule ball the
teacher wasn't so excited about the
upcoming party in the book
but in the film she was much more into
it getting ron up in front of everyone
else to show them how it's done
poor ron is mortified much to the
amusement of fred
george and harry never gonna let him
forget this
are you never the scene in the
half-blood prince movie when bellatrix
lestrange and fenrir greyback attack the
weasley's house is so iconic
that lego made a whole set based on it
but it's not
actually in the book so why did the film
producers create this devastating moment
well there's a fan theory that makes a
lot of sense firstly
it moves harry and ginny's relationship
forward with the pair's bond growing
it provides action to the middle section
of the movie which otherwise would have
been devoid of any major moment
and we also see lupine and tonks as a
couple plus it gives helena bonham
carter
more air time
we get a lot of details in the half
blood prince book about dumbledore's
passing and his funeral
but the movie provides an extra moment
of mourning that really moves us
after harry goes over to the body and
the students and staff all watch on in
utter sadness
professor mcgonagall raises her wand to
the sky the rest of the mourners follow
her lead and we see a sea of wands held
aloft to honor their late headmaster
the overhead view is stunning with all
the lit tips of the wands
shining upwards and the accompanying
instrumental music
perfectly matches the melancholy scene
[Music]
in the opening of half-blood prince film
harry is reading the daily prophet in a
cafe
he flirts with a waitress and when she
turns her back he hilariously checks his
breath and pops a mint in his mouth
they even plan a date but dumbledore
turns up and that's the end of that
it's a fun scene that shows harry acting
like a regular person who isn't always
preoccupied with saving the world
it replaces the book scene where harry's
reading the paper at the dursleys and
dumbledore turns up at four privet drive
we would have loved to see that happen
too she was truthfully
very pretty the girl one of harry's most
endearing features is his ability
to crack an unexpected joke and he does
this in a scene during the half-blood
prince when hermione is trying to help
him figure out who to take to slughorn's
christmas party
she tells him that ramilda vayne trying
to smuggle you a love potion
harry's funny reply shows a sense of
humor and that he can have light-hearted
moments about being a reluctant
celebrity
she's only interested in you because she
thinks you're the chosen one
this moment in the half-blood prince
isn't an entire scene that's unique to
the film
but rather a few funny sections that
didn't appear in the book
perry taking professor slughorn down to
hagrid's for aragog's funeral features
in both the book
and the movie but dan radcliffe's
impression of a giant spider with
pincers
is particular to the film and it's a
wonderful bit of light relief
in the deathly hallows part 2 film we
get an extra draco moment that jk
rowling didn't create
but which shows how he's torn between
loyalty to his family
and his deep down desire to be a better
guy when his parents summon him over to
their side after the battle of hogwarts
something seriously creepy happens lord
voldemort reaches out and gives draco
the most awkward hug
ever well done
the looks on the faces of the students
watching the disturbing scene
sum up how creeped out we feel too jk
rowling gives harry
and us readers some much welcome
information about harry's mom
through slughorn's memories of lily
these translate from the book to the
film but we also get an extra insight
into lily's personality in the
half-blood prince movie
that rowling didn't include in the book
slughorn reveals that lily made him a
pet fish
which she created out of a flower petal
and the fish vanished when she passed
away
it's a touching moment which provides a
greater insight into just how kind lily
was
our battle had come from a lily
your mother during the battle of
hogwarts in the deathly hallows part 2
neville has a heroic moment where he
leads the snatchers across the covered
wooden bridge
in the book it's mentioned that neville
dueled scabior
and some snatchers met their fate by
falling from the bridge
but in the film adaptation it's
elaborated we see professor mcgonagall
telling neville and sheamus to use
pyrotechnics to rig the bridge
and then we see the visually impressive
moment when the bridge collapses
it might not have been in jk rowling's
original vision but we're in favor of
neville having more chances to shine
that went well there's a whole character
who appears in the movies that doesn't
even exist in the books
and that's nigel wolpert a gryffindor we
first meet in the goblet of fire film
he becomes a member of dumbledore's army
and has that pollen creevy style
admiration of harry
and the squad in fact it's thought that
nigel was a replacement for colin who
continued to feature in the books until
the end
but only appeared in the chamber of
secrets movie nigel popped up in various
scenes
always eager to help he even delivered
ron's mail hoping that he'd get harry's
autograph in return
bless
there's another moment in the deathly
hallows part 2 that's particular to the
movie
when snape calls an assembly after
hearing that harry was spotted in
hogsmeade
harry doesn't stay under the
invisibility cloak in front of the whole
school
can confront snape about his role in
dumbledore's passing
mcgonagall and snape's stool follows
before cerberus escapes
how dare you stand where he stood in the
deathly hallows book hermione reveals to
harry that she used the obliviate spell
to wipe herself from her parents
memories
but in the movie we actually get to
watch the moment it happens
it's an emotional scene and helps the
audience connect much more deeply with
hermione's pain
than if we had simply watched her tell
harry about it
as with many of these scenes it can be
presented differently on screen because
the films aren't so closely tied to only
showing what harry is experiencing
that allows us viewers to develop
greater empathy with other characters
the movies charted hermione and ron's
changing relationship really well
but they took a few liberties with the
source material along the way
like in the chamber of secrets film when
hermione joined her friends again after
being cured from being petrified
she rushes up to harry and gives him a
big hug and then she turns to ron
they both lean in for a hug but instead
they settle for an awkward handshake
it's a perfect way to sum up their
complicated relationship but it didn't
actually happen in the book that way
which of these scenes do you think earns
its place in the movies the most
and which one do you think isn't worthy
of messing with jk's original vision
let us know in the comments section and
give this video a like if you love the
wizarding world
until next time potterheads thanks for
watching
[Music]